what's going on comic nation and welcome
to another episode of media vs. comics
for those of you guys who are new this
is a series where we take a look at
various comic book characters and teams
from across both DC and Marvel and we
compare them to their movie counterparts
and we ask the question which one's
better the comic book version or the
movie version and in this video we're
going to be talking about Captain
America
so what's really cool about Captain
America and Marvel Comics is that we
couldn't quite literally trace the
growth of Marvel from the 1960s up until
the current day by simply looking at
Steve Rogers and this is where his
character becomes unique and the
comic-book versions and the comic books
themselves Steve Rogers initially starts
off in the 1960s as a reflection of the
1960s he does what needs to be done but
society wasn't ready for a darker
character they weren't ready for the
kind of character that we see in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe version of
Steve Rogers Steve Rogers has the
leadership I guess concept he has a
leadership role where he basically
almost immediately becomes a Lear of the
Avengers after he is found and revived
by the Avengers and Avengers issue
number four but from that point going
forward he really wasn't as hard-hitting
and as dark as we had usually seen he
was more methodical he was the planner
he was the person that said there always
has to be a way to do the right thing
now this really changed entirely once we
got into the 2000s because by that point
we now had the ultimate universe of
Marvel Comics and the Ultimate Universe
was a reimagining of Marvel characters
for a more modern age I guess is the
best way to put it and so Marvel had to
find a way to also keep their earth-616
continuity relevant in the face of the
ultimate universe's existence and so
this is when we started to see Captain
America become a little darker and do
the kind of things it needs to be done
and this really came to a head with
civil war civil war was when we saw
Captain America step into the role of
being pushed to the limit we had never
really seen a point where Captain
America had become that dark where he
had become that sinister where he was so
lost and the I guess the message of what
it was he was trying to achieve that he
forgot what the actual goal was he
became a character who basically went
underground who started using guerrilla
warfare tactics who saw Tony Stark and
shield as an enemy as opposed to a group
that he should have been working with
and this was really highlighted more so
than anything as we discuss in our civil
war series once Civil War began to come
to an end and we saw that an interview
was conducted with Captain America where
he was basically told he lost his way he
just hasn't quite I guess gotten back to
the roots of what it was that made him
effective in the first place now with
the Marvel Cinematic Universe version of
Civil War
I'm sorry of Captain America was really
cool about him is that he immediately is
the character that we know from Civil
War and this
what's really intriguing Captain America
from the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
effectively Captain America from mark
Miller's Civil War that's the Captain
America that we see as soon as Chris
Evans steps onto the scene as Captain
America it's no-holds-barred he does
whatever it is it needs to be done and
he has no qualms about stepping into the
role and telling people that they're
wrong about stepping into the role and
telling people they need to change
things otherwise they're gonna find
themselves and society as a whole in a
very dark place and this was never more
evident than the scene we saw in Captain
America the Winter Soldier and when
Chris Evans was conversing with Nick
Fury and stated that this new I guess
weapons program that he had basically
implemented alongside Tony Stark was not
freedom that it was fear this really
highlights the Mark Miller version of
civil war most or more so than anything
that we have ever seen in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with Captain America
thus far in addition to this and what we
found was that with Captain America in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and his
conflicts with Grum low and his
conflicts with other individuals with a
shield as a whole one shield have been
taken over by Hydra this was again the
very essence of civil war Captain
America and so the question has to be
asked here at the end of the day if we
had to compare one to the other if we
had to look at Captain America from
Civil War and from the comic book
industry as a whole and we had to look
at Captain America from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe which one comes out
on top here which one is the absolute
best
is it the comic book version or is it
the movie version honestly my vote goes
to the comic book version
I think the comic book version of
Captain America is a little bit better
here and there's a couple reasons for
this the first reason is because with
the Marvel Cinematic Universe version of
Captain America we've seen one dynamic
of him we've seen one element of him
he's fighting on behalf of freedom and
that's it that's really all we've seen
with his character that's because a lot
of the stories that we've seen I guess
so the movies that we see with Captain
America so far have always been in the
mists of conflict has never really been
an instance where he's been able to stay
away from conflict and they've been able
to focus on him as a character in terms
of what makes Steve Rogers tick we've
gotten a little bit of this in the sense
that we saw his reaction or I guess his
interaction with Peggy Carter after she
had developed Alzheimer's and Captain
America the Winter Soldier we saw his
interactions with Peggy Carter and
Captain
the First Avenger and we of course saw
his interaction with other members of
the team in in the Avengers film now
what I will give Captain America from
the lawful Cinematic Universe credit for
is that he maintains the same kind of
leadership role as he did in the comics
he's just as effective in the comic
books and in terms of leadership as he
is in the Marvel Cinematic Universe but
at the end of the day this is really
just a circumstance whereby the catalog
of Captain America's stories and Marvel
Comics is so large that there's just so
much to the character in the comics that
we've seen in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and so it may be then a year
from now it may be the two or three or
four years from now that once we finish
with infinity war and we get more into
the model Cinematic Universe and future
phases that his character may each span
but for right now I've got to give this
one to Captain America from the comic
books with that being said let me know
how you guys feel let me know which one
you guys prefer it let me know in the
comments section what other characters
you'd like me to do videos on with
regards to media vs. comics with that
being said I will catch you guys later
pretty be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comments explained and talk
to me directly